don't even look at me you don't deserve
to look at this the mattress of this
show is
standards unfortunately you're a worm
with a
with a Peter pump rules reunion without
some name-calling poo poo head both of
you poo poo heads James threats of
violence giving my face is gonna open
you up
oh my cards there was nothing left unset
or talk of in this case the cheating
scandal to end all cheating scandals I
have been super selfish selfish does not
cover it diabolical demented
subhuman they're making you and me to be
pathological Liars I see that yeah even
though we know that we're not and this
year I kind of did a deep dive and
experienced new things yeah plenty of
new things in the first look at Bravo's
three-part TV event I'm gonna get
central timeout
kicking off May 24th she has a long
history of diminishing my friendships
that situation change how you feel about
Raquel oh my opinion ever couldn't be
lower I do have something for you this
was filed today I believe
you threw it all up in the air and
you've got to see where it lands of
course there's another kind of reunion
walking this way you ready
yeah Chris and Dodie's back in next
week's finale meanwhile two more pass
faves Jackson Britney Raquel and
Sandoval are hooking up giving
commentary to scandival on peacock
feeling that she kind of has a crush on
someone else yeah
I've been where he is it's the awful
awful place I just feel so bad for
Ariana James and Lala can't talk because
they
wasn't your best friend the authenticity
of the show where people really talk
about their real lives and their
feelings is what keeps people engaged
The Immortal became like really good
friends I don't give a [__]
[Music]
with Anderson Cooper yesterday and
someone came up to ask us about the
Revenge dress you don't deserve to look
at this that's why it hurts that's why
people bled by Ariana as for the show's
future season 11 confirmed by Bravo on
Tuesday we need a break from filming me
I don't want a camera my [__] goddamn
face no word on casting but Tom Sandoval
clearly over his new reality Tom
you are in love
come on it's a very simple question are
you in love or are you not
well Ariana
's question for et what have you learned
post scandival
when did you find out that they're
[__] dude late August told me that
August
what does not put your timelines
together to match right now it's a mess
[Music]
[Laughter]